and here we are just as promised we are
doing a double feature on today's movie
retrospective one of the greatest
Vampire Chronicles of all times Blacula
and screen black of the screen actually
two of my favorite vampire movies they
are actually very good vampire but a
very good vampire but weeks for the time
the acting and it is very good and Anne
Rice ripped off a lot of the ideas from
her vampire chronicles from this yeah I
like she probably did and this movie had
a lot of influence in other movies yeah
I'll get into that a bit but how I
discovered these movies I think is kind
of an interesting story when I was
living in the New Orleans area I was
hanging out in a club and I fell in with
this old guy it was a it was a goth club
you know but I fell in with this old guy
who kind of had an appreciation for the
goth subculture even though he was a old
retired New Orleans pimp by the
mammillary I don't know his street name
or where his pen name was he left that
he left the pimp game behind him he got
too old for it now eventually he ran
afoul in terms of money and got
desperate and became a bank robber and
got caught was necessary the bank round
yeah he ended up being a Larry the bank
robber but you know that was prison was
his retirement plan he didn't have you
know anything really to look forward to
so he went out with a bang I mean you
know he was in his 60s
yeah you can't blame the guy so uh heard
about these from Larry to pimp and when
he first started telling me it was cool
to you know he'd blow me all these books
like iceberg slim they were like yeah
he's very slim let me like four of them
one of them was like pimp man you know
and that was part of my pimp training
although part of our town training well
he took me under his wing a little bit
you know cuz he liked how I dressed and
he was a said you know God's or kind of
you know you you kind of remind me of a
pimp we're kind of like yeah like the
various dark pimps yeah and it was like
a slight levendi's pimps nuts ash and it
was a subculture you know you he
appreciated that
the time I was wearing you know the hide
Doc Martens the PVC pants and the you
know seven 1800s style jacket like front
coats so yeah the frock coats and so you
know that you know there's an aspect of
dandy as exactly and you know that's the
way the New Orleans pimp was all
attempts from his era were like that and
you know he told me that you know a man
had to keep his pimp ham holstered you
know I had to keep it holstered up every
now and then and my pimp hand is 45
caliber I'm looking at it right now yes
you know are listed as I rotate it
anyway pimp and in three dimensions
anyway Larry told me about these and
when I first heard about him you know
just cuz the title I was like madness
he's gotta be these things gotta suck I
kind of feel like that's a common
misperception black blaxploitation
movies when I eventually was able to
rent them and see them I was I was
pleasantly surprised that you know they
were actually pretty nice too you
actually are pretty good they're good
stories of good characters the title
Blacula it's it's an incendiary title
yeah
but back in the day that's what you had
to have a sell a movie like this you're
a target marketing it right to the
audience you know they were high quality
movies they were African American
productions the guy that actually the
guys that worked on them were mostly
black these things were crafted very
well for the time the stories were good
the explanation for how he got his name
is in there the costumes are fantastic
and the casting was good Pam Grier a lot
of yeah and she was in the sequel yeah
its William Marshall and William
Marshall if you guys don't know who
William Marshall is if you ever watch
the old Star Trek he was the dr.
daystrom
the m5 computer yeah is that guy and the
guy has a fantastic voice or you know
children of the 80s will recognize him
as the king of cartoons from pee-wee's
Playhouse
okay yeah it's it's sad because I feel
like William Marshall he was an actor's
director he's a lot of theater work he
was in a lot of TV shows I think he was
in a I want to say he was in a Twilight
Zone episode
like that he did some TV work and he did
a few movies but I feel like he didn't
get as much work as he probably should
have he wasn't he was a Shakespearean
actor he was in class arraigned yeah it
came early - he was like a man ahead of
his time yeah yes that's definitely the
case he was the original black heavy who
took his place was James Earl Jones yeah
I actually think in James Earl Jones was
inspired by William Marshall because if
you if you really listened to the voice
of Blacula okay that is really the voice
of Darth Vader right and we're not the
first piece of people to notice this
because we watched welcome to the
basement which is what probably my
favorite man show ever they did a review
of scream Blacula scream and they
mentioned that they wondered if maybe
Darth Vader had been inspired by Blacula
watch you sorry
why don't you spoon in some black it up
going on one of his little rants and the
audience could hear how close this
sounds to Darth Vader yeah good evening
gentlemen I say are you looking for me
I guess I should have told you this
evening that I decided to move my coffin
but then it gave me the idea that we got
plant patina you know nothing of that
life means more to me than my own does
it
I could dispense with you now doctor but
I have a rather urgent appointment
elsewhere
[Music]
so I like drive a turret yeah when you
think about it the character of Darth
Vader was a freed slave who was in all
black and he had William Marshall or
blackulas voice coming out of it and in
a way Vader was a vampire and he was a
Frankenstein Vader had to feed off the
life force of his master who was Kia you
are like a psychic vampire than a
physical vampire same kind of thing and
seemingly at the genesis of Darth
Vader's creation he must have been at
the brink of death and Lord Sidious
saved him from the grave remember
because he learned how to keep people
from dying
so Vader was also the undead and he also
was in a mechanical suit and merged with
machine which is in a way maybe he's a
cyborg but it's also a life-support
system possibly kind of like a
Frankenstein monster - yeah well Blacula
is the original throw off a door if you
want to look at it that way yeah there
are a lot of parallels with those two
characters I would definitely agree with
that
because I should say the first Blacula
came out in 1972 and then the sequel
scream Blacula scream which actually the
working title of it was Blacula is
beautiful unless I kind of wish they
called it that is that's kind of an
awesome title scream Blacula scream
that's pretty good too but Blacula is
beautiful yeah that's pretty good that
one came out a year later in 1973 now I
think most people tend to like the first
movie better hmm it's definitely a more
culturally significant Israel
action-packed it yeah it's faster paced
um I think and like I said it has a lot
of cultural importance because it was
kind of like the first the first time
that a better black man had portrayed a
vampire on film he's also portrayed even
though he's clearly a monster he's
portrayed very sympathetically yeah well
it wasn't his choice to be brave and
that's kind of something that's cool
about the first one is that you know you
see at the beginning of the movie that
he and his wife who's named Luva they've
actually they don't know that Dracula is
a vampire he's just like a count or
whatever so they come to his castle and
they're trying to get his cooperation
enough stop the slavers to help
trade black.this original birth name was
mumble Walden yeah he's a prince yeah
and he was a prince of some African
nation that was there I don't even think
they meant I don't think they named it
honestly and he went to talk to this
European guy yeah it seems to be the
1700s and trying to get him to help
develop Africa through trade and part of
the thing was is to stop the slave trade
right
Dracula really you know he wasn't for
that Dracula immediately just shows he's
a complete nutter snatch napkin drag is
just kind of like it was profited hey
can i buy your wisest yeah I want to buy
your wife too you know mom and mom out
here you are a savage yeah you know
Dracula grabs him and takes him and his
wife down to his - and curses him and
bites mama Waldie and turns him into a
vampire and he says you're gonna be
cursed through all eternity sealed in
this casket yeah wanting blood and not
being able to getting blood and not
wanting to get him not being able to get
out of this casket and get it and your
wife is gonna die in here with this tomb
listen you're gonna listen to her
screams yeah and he goes and I'm gonna
name you Blacula ya know so it was not
it was not mama wall days choice to
become of em he was forced into it he
was given that name rot and it was his
vampire name as a pimp as a pimp named
bad pirate name that was black killin it
was forced on him but throughout the as
the movie started continues over the
course of the two movies when he gets
mad he kind of embraces that character
that was a forced on him yeah more so in
the second millisecond right because in
the first one he still kind of feels
like you know he was supposed to be
sealed in the tomb forever but then it
happens and in 1972 there are two castle
troops Castle trakis Castle Dracula
there are two antique dealers who are
like the biggest gay stereotypes as yeah
yeah yeah it's like a biracial bromance
which is why you went in a black that's
cool if they [ __ ] it on TV but they were
just like so there and they're also both
really stereotypical for being white and
very stupid yeah for being black and
very stereotypical for being gay but you
know what it was funny yeah it was it
was funny it was respectful they were
well I don't know if I'd say I think it
was but if it was kind of like it's
funny to see it as like a cultural relic
for the seventies yeah that's a good way
of doing they were rich and very
successful they were independent they
were buying Castle Castle Dracula yeah
and they were the shown is having being
rich and having good taste which say
that you can check all those boxes yeah
true that's you know so but they are the
ones that unwittingly release Blacula
because they bought a lot from Castle
Dracula because of all the antiques and
stuff and then when they bring it to Los
Angeles they decide to open the coffin
because they think it's neat and Blacula
gets out and um and you know
subsequently goes on a rampage now it
should be noted that like it like I said
before because it's a title and even
before I had seen it because we saw it
many years ago and we've seen it several
times since then I've read I've seen it
a bunch of times yeah and it always
seems a little bit different every time
I see it I get the two movies confused a
lot yeah there's a lot of crossover and
there's some crossover and they were
made rather close together and I said
there's more than one edit of the first
one because in the first one I remember
some conversations happening that are in
my copy and they weren't in the rental
from YouTube it had to do with slavery
but it would have been cut yeah because
I feel like that was kind of a cool
angle but what I was gonna say was that
big I think because of the title people
who have never seen either Blacula movie
I mean you would be forgiven for
thinking that this was gonna be a
straight-up blaxploitation and a comedy
and yeah kind of movie and a comedy it's
gonna be super cheesy like and you know
they made other ones later blackenstein
which I would not recommend because that
was buried blackenstein sucked it was
very very yet it just was very cheaply
Meiji it looked like it cost about a
buck 98 on a good black and say could've
it's just that they didn't they didn't
put any money there was also a movie
later on called a be the
it's alternate channel is the black sir
cyst we're gonna put it all away yeah we
got a yeah I don't know it's formerly
called that but that's generally how
it's referred exam times yeah but the
thing about this is that I don't even I
don't think I would call it a
blaxploitation movie because pretty much
it's it's pretty much a straight up yeah
traditional vampire Dracula story blacks
jokes with black actors term and set in
the black community the term
blaxploitation I don't agree with that
term black people wanted to see movies
with black people in them yeah okay and
that's why these movies came about they
weren't exploiting black people they
were giving debt that audience what they
wanted to see you know I mean you like
Dracula right well when you like to see
a black track that if you're black so
that thus Blacula yeah see that I'm
white I saw that I like that so I think
the term blaxploitation came from
outside the industry people well it's
funny because pretty much now every kind
of sleazy different kind of movie has a
split ation we taste like Nazis ploy
Taoiseach or we watch it because no
exploitation yes so I don't think it's
necessarily a disparaging term but you
think it was black people making these
movies yeah well particularly wasn't
this so hot yes so how was it yeah it
was a black directors meeting that a man
right there many of them by that same
token you could say that Night of the
Living Dead is possibly blasted
blaxploitation and there's no way that's
blaxploitation know that was you know
that I had a black male lead probably
one of the best black leads in all of
horror and if that mostly played when it
opened that mostly planted black
theaters yeah definitely the black kids
loved it well they had never seen it I
never saw him like that and there's a
[ __ ] great scene where black dude
beats down white guy yeah and he
deserved it yeah no white art he's like
yeah beat that [ __ ] his ass yeah that
wasn't something you saw back this well
the thing about it too and you know
we'll get back to black in a second yeah
you know the thing about that was that
that was totally accidental because
George Romero yeah when he wrote that
role he didn't [ __ ] of it as a
particular race he just that was a guy
he knew who was a good actor and he's
like oh he was just the best one so we
put him in the movie we weren't really
shows you the difference of an
organically created character and an
artificially created character something
yeah so all this stuff that has been
just was ignited the long-dead but you
can see how black audiences really
responded to that because that was
something you hardly ever saw black
leading man where his race was not
really rubber - well he's just a man and
that's what made that that's what made
that roll so believable he's a man he's
a man first that's the same thing with
an alien one the Ripley character was
not written to be as a woman yes Ripley
was just the last name Ripley
yeah they thought maybe it was a man but
then they cast a woman who said that
works too yeah either way that's why
she's one of the best female action yeah
because the hero specifically
specifically try to go out of their way
to make a super woman
that's not no it's just a place she was
just a park just a person yeah and and
that's what that's why a lot of these
so-called blaxploitation things that
that term doesn't work for me I think
that came from outside
yeah the industry but what I was trying
to say was that you know you could be
forgiven for thinking because of the
title there's gonna be super cheesy and
stupid or silly or funny or comedic
through it and it's really not and I
think most of that and I mean I'm not
because all of the actors are good and
all of them take their roles pretty
seriously yeah other than like I said
there's some humor with like the
over-the-top gay stereotypes and stuff
yeah but generally I mean William
Marshall who plays Blacula yeah he is a
Shakespearean actor it shows he's a true
heavy he's not attending to be a heavy
he is a heavy he was a university
professor this guy was an intellectual
and an opera singer and an opera singer
which you can tell because he has a
beautiful beautiful voice so if you're
gonna play a vampire that's the guy you
want the cool thing about his character
- like I said is that particularly in
the first movie you know the whole plot
around it's not like a super original
plot it's you know a generally vampire
plot with you know it's like you know oh
it's it's the reincarnation of his wife
Luva you know he comes to 1972 and he
meets a woman that's the you know played
by the same actress and so he starts to
pursue a relationship with her you know
meanwhile killing people on the side but
you can kind of see how as monstrous as
his character I mean he's a vampire he
kills people and when he gets into vamp
mode he almost
kind of looks like he goes where wolfy
kinda it's like more hair and because
banks and stuff kind of cross a werewolf
and a vampire back yeah that's kind of
but yet you could still see it's totally
understandable how you would fall for
him anyway
yeah because he's totally suave he's
gentlemanly he's real slick and he seems
like a nice person despite all the
killing yeah you know what I mean so
that really makes it worse still a
vampire he really does sell better and
in the second one they they bring in a
voodoo element yeah and I really liked
having which which I like yeah yeah
instead of equating voodoo with Satanism
which they usually did they did that all
the way up into the 80s
voodoo was just treated as a meta as a
Caribbean religion really yeah which is
what it what if that's kind of cool and
I feel like that was way ahead of its
time
oh I should know too one of the best
things about these two movies one the
soundtrack yeah kick-ass yeah there's
this real funky soundtrack really cool
also the costume costume the the the
clothes on the guys and the girls are
fantastic you could wear him you could
wear that now to the club and okay that
purple thing yeah that she wears in it
first movie uh Tina I think her name is
Tina yeah it's got a hood on the purple
thing with the hood the dress and it
awesome I want that outfit yeah and in
the second movie the voodoo priest who
got turned into a vampire what was his
name I forgot Willis Willis that's right
Willis is sooo [ __ ] fantastic that's
it that was badass that that he was
wearing well when he first gets turned
into the vampire he looks in the mirror
he can't see himself yeah he goes I
can't see myself
how can a brother G even dress how'd he
live his life not being able to see how
he looks you know you will stay here
yeah he did look fly though I told him
through the screen but yeah so that was
cool but yeah that I feel like scream
Blacula scream although it's not as I
mean the plot of it is pretty similar to
the first one and it's not quite as
action-packed but I feel like the Voodoo
element of it like gave it something a
little something something
I kind of liked a little bit better you
know I like them both a lot but the
second one I thought that was really
cool and like you said it seemed really
progressive for the time that they had
this vote you know I don't want to call
it a cult really but it was just like a
group of people that did voodoo and Pam
Grier was the head of it and it wasn't
portrayed as a bad thing like you could
do bad things with it like Willis was
the one that brought Blacula back from
the dead cuz he had his bones and he did
a voodoo spell and everything like that
and he brought him back but he played
with us was really cool it kind of
remind me of prance a little bit you
know who it's like the whole time I was
like gah what else was he in because it
was bugging me he was in poltergeist oh
he was one of the parapsychologist
remember the ones that came to the
Freeling house okay okay I was like God
I knew I'd seen him so that's where I
recognized no and another thing I liked
about this movie what's up in the screen
blacklist screamed the cop the cop who
were the black cop who worked on the
force oh yeah yeah whatever he talks to
the white guys he would go full hockey
on he was even aware that he was doing
score see I hope he was how you doing
man well we've got to get back to work
yeah he was he was talking to white
people he would he would go fellow
hockey he would affect a white person
voice and it was like it it was very 70s
white guy it was very famous Valerius I
like it's I didn't notice that the first
time that I watched it but then were you
watched it again yeah oh my god he is
doing a that's awesome when he's
probably getting back at like all the
times that like these stupid painfully
white people would try to be like hey
soul brother and like yeah this bump or
some [ __ ] he's just like yeah I'm just
gonna fight a stereotypical white person
how do you like it I can you know I can
I can work in both worlds you know I
speak their language man he was kind of
used me get me stewardess I speak hockey
you just put that right airplane yeah
but yeah I like that so yeah so I
thought it was cool that they just
portrayed voodoo is something that was
and the guy that was the cop right
actually was a former cop he was the
hero and also Pam Grier was kind of the
hero and
voodoo priestess yes and all the
actresses are good all the actors and
all the actresses are good there aren't
any bad actor actress actress oh now
they're everybody's good and you know to
cast the main parts of the cast they're
all hot they're all good-looking yeah
male or female why I mean Pam Grier
obviously bunch of good-looking black
women
Vanetta mcgee women Tina and loofah in
the first one holy cow she is like
supernaturally yeah well and they had
the 70s fashion perfect for the movie
with a with a totally round afros and
stuff yeah it looked [ __ ] awesome
yeah and I really liked all the like all
the sets were beautiful like everything
was really all the sets were better in
the second one and that's what yeah it
was filmed that yeah the second one is a
higher quality movie yeah not quite as
action-packed but like a baby yeah it's
different you know it does move a little
bit more slowly yeah the first one I
will concede that and I will attest it
these movies are very good if you're
drinking because it just kind of get
boys you could just kind of get lost in
the scenery and them talking and Blacula
is a very magnetic character oh no yeah
definitely when he's talking you just
kind of kind of zone out a little bit
you know kind of like in the way when
you look Kitty's own hat with mr. Rogers
and talk to you yeah a little bit I did
I noticed that I noticed you doing that
yeah cuz he's relaxing or something I
don't know he would have been a really
good hypnotist yeah that's why he was
really good at playing Dracula because
when he talked he has this beautiful
like so nurus voice yeah and he always
sounds authoritative right but you know
he but he it's very smooth it's very
musical yeah now he's cut out very much
like an African and analogy to Vlad
Tepes yeah or the or the Dracula from
Romania he's all into African culture
not so much into african-american
culture remember he wouldn't kill those
pimps in his get one yeah no you know he
wasn't he wasn't down with any kind of
ghetto stuff remember that he went after
those pimps saying that they were just
doing nothing but enslaving your sisters
he's dating your sister so there's a
through line of slavery through both of
the men you
enslaving your sisters and your
impersonating your old masters right you
know just but then the cool thing and I
was telling you this the other day the
ironic thing about the Blacula movies
though is that as against slavery as
Blacula was I mean he became Blacula
simply because he went to Dracula's
castle to try to get his help in saving
it but that was part of his curse that
was the curse that Dracula the white man
put on him he was cursed to make slaves
out of people because when he bits you
you became a vampire right and precisely
they told Jesus you know you're my
slaves
yeah and particularly the character of
Willis in the second movie who is sort
of like he's a vampire he makes him a
vampire but he's he seems like he has a
little bit more on the ball than the
other ones like the other ones just
seemed kind of like monsters or zombies
but Willis still seemed like a human you
more or less there she was like a
Renfield sort of character now there's a
missing scene I remember it well because
when I ever saw it I said oh this is
where Anne Rice got this angle from
doing this and that and I believe it was
he out of Murph it was the first one the
second one but it's not in either
blu-rays there was a scene where Blacula
tells one of his newly made vampires
says what are you gonna do you're gonna
go out you're gonna go out to the club
and mingle with with mortals they will
find out where you live they will find
out what you are find out where you live
and you'll lead them back here and
they'll kill us all and that was part of
it and then the other thing he said was
then there was something along the lines
where after he told him that he said you
can't be free I've made you you belong
to me you are my slaves yeah that's well
he there was some of that when he was
talking to Willis when he first when
Willis comes down and is looking in the
mirror he can't see himself I think
there was there was a little bit of a
speech there was telling him you know
you can't go anywhere you think you're
just gonna give us up in the first movie
that that scene came from my happy
because he was talking to a group of him
and after he said that they all want
like oh man
we're slaves you know what's cool to be
a vampire if you became a vampire the
head vampire was your master you know
and you much like I said that was kind
of like the irony or more of the curse
of what your game is
yeah it basically it made him into what
he despised so in a way it made him more
of a tragic character like you said in
the second movie he kind of embraced
embraced that a little bit because I
brought you up yes there's killing all
the cop although it should be noted kill
some cops but he kill a lot of cops he
did yeah yeah because his his whole
quest in the second movie was that you
know since he'd been brought back to
life unwittingly by voodoo magic he was
trying to befriend Lisa Pam Greer's
character who was a voodoo priestess he
thought that she would be able to take
off the curse so that he could die right
so that's what he was spending movie
doing so it's not necessarily that he
embraced the role he he seemed like he
did but he still didn't he still wanted
to end it yeah he was I think that's
where Anne Rice got a lot of stuff about
in Anne Rice's Vampire Chronicles about
walking off into the Sun BAM yeah it's
dying of their own hand and just like
remember how Louie didn't want to be a
vampire yeah it kind of wanted to end it
I think that's where Anne Rice I think
Anne Rice got those damn for those
elements of vampirism I think she got
those ideas from these two movies
because there's no other vampire movies
that have those not really enough of not
one about being a vampire not really
wanting to be a vampire not that I can
remember that that came later I think
that came from this yeah because I don't
really remember Dracula being no that
was more a Frankenstein thing yeah you
know where Frankenstein's monster
Dracula was all about being a vampire
you didn't see the rock yeah he was just
like it that's how he's gonna get harem
yeah that's pretty kick-ass yeah but
yeah Blacula even though he didn't I
mean from seeing to see and he didn't
seem to mind it but there there was just
kind of this underlying thing the whole
time where he's just really trying to
figure out a way to get out because I
mean I don't want to give away the end
of the best movie this movie is well
known enough to give it give a lot of
ways yeah but you know he's he's
definitely it's definitely trying
something that he's trying to get out
from underneath yeah you know despite
how ok with it he appears now I think
this is a pretty good teaser if you
haven't seen the movies I read them
pretty well don't expect the special
effects to be impressive particularly
some makeup on the on the vampires that
he makes are really not all that good
there and it's also by today's standards
not scary vampires are not scary to me
they're cool I like the movies but yeah
scary I don't think I've ever seen a
scary vampire maybe no they're from the
Victorian era and those people would
just faint there were the littlest
things you know it's one that was just
the corset or yeah they couldn't bring
it ya know that it's not scary but it is
cool it has a couple of kind of creepy
set pieces I feel like you know that one
scene where he's kind of coming down the
hall like drifting down the hall that's
like that's kind of scary and that one
vampire that comes up off the slab and
kind of runs down the hall in slow
motion that's pretty creepy that visual
what I thought was cool was just how all
the different kind of cultures clashed
or interacted white black vampire mortal
top civilian cop criminal there's a
bunch of different elements yeah I mean
a bunch of different kinds of people
interacting with one yeah it's
definitely it was I mean it was
definitely a cool movie yet it's of its
time yeah but in a way I think it was
also ahead of its time
yeah and it's you can still learn from
it by watching it today so little story
nuances and there's just you know yeah
and and just the fashion the fashion
looked really cool and like I said I
mean William Marshall really kind of
elevated ya elevated the movie I mean he
was just such a such a great actor
integrate blows you can go to get both
movies on one blu-ray for about ten
dollars delivered you know off of ebay
and you know you sit sit back and watch
a double feature and drink some tequila
or something you know just have a good
time watching what we did okay anyway so
if you have enjoyed this review of
Blacula and scream Blacula scream and if
you enjoy all of our reviews and our
episodes then please like share
subscribe tell all your friends about us
also if you'd like to financially
support the show you can go to our
patreon page which is patreon.com slash
13 o'clock podcast or go to our blog
which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation and be
sure to check out our regular episodes
which come out every Tuesday and our
movie retrospectives which come out
every friday and that will do it for
this installment we will see you next
time bye
is Blacula keep that pimp hand holster